so when you like when you are in in the
producer role when it's like you're and
you have 12 directors you said that work
for you yeah
um as a producer like how much input do
you have on everything well I think what
I do is like I just try to lead by
experience right you got me because a
lot of directors have the talent but
sometimes you know I think you know
filmmakers can get a little weird you
got me and they're like they're not
they're more worried about the real than
the artist's career and I try to worry
about both and I think that's what makes
my video so special and because you know
before I was even like doing any video
stuff like I actually like I used to in
high school I used to like uh freestyle
battle rap people like and I was going
to school to school rapping and stuff
and I wanted to be a rapper right and
then I was like and then I started like
you kind of you know you're growing up
your Spanish kid
um you know like you know you're like in
a predominantly black neighborhood and
you're like damn I can't really rap you
know like I don't have that confidence
as a 17 year old so I was like you know
what let me pick up a camera maybe I
could just shoot you got me and then
that's kind of what happened and um yeah
so like I think like I also am kind of
in a way like some like some deep down
part inside me I have this music artist
ability in me that just wants to like
understand who artists are and what
they're trying to accomplish you know
you also have a record label yes do
everything records yeah with the homie
Jordan from QC right yes 100 so yeah um
talk about the artist y'all got the I
forget the young ladies yeah I have my
record label do everything records and
he has the wasted Youth and we merged
and we did a partnership with Warner to
sign a girl named Ivy four that's right
yeah yeah so what's that I mean
obviously that's that's a whole nother
bag of that was something to prove to
myself just because like you know I was
working with so many artists and um
helping them develop and I was like you
know what I want something that I can
like you know stamp my name on and be
like yo you know I really started from
the ground up and and like you know
without any confusion and just being
like you know sometimes you're like oh
is it me or was it them or was it us and
I think it's a us thing but of course it
should be enough yeah and then uh unless
you're Russ then it's like really just
you and him because yes was like
managing himself yeah but um it was cool
because with Ivy um yeah she liked my
photo and you know she Esau Russ and
then she saw who shot his videos and
it's so funny how like one thing
connects to the other right and then I
was looking for a girl with box braids
for a music video for Atlantic Records
and I saw her uh I saw her face and I
was like oh she would be a perfect model
I reached out to her and then I was like
yo do you want to be in this video and
she's like well I live in New York but
yeah I'm down I was like yeah the
video's tomorrow so how soon can you get
here and she's like oh well the flight's
like 800 and I was like music video
budget at the time I'm like yeah I don't
got the money so she flew herself in
still met with me and then um yeah
pulled up at me like at two in the
morning and like sang for me and I was
just like yo you know what give me 90
days give me three months and I'll come
back for you and I just said that
because I was busy doing some other
videos at the time and Lily on the 90th
day I called her back and I said yo I
partnered with Jordan and I'm like yo
let's do this together we all hopped on
the phone and we did that within a week
we had a million dollar offer from
Sylvia Rona epic [ __ ] because in that
week we made five songs and we shot five
videos all in that same week
um a guy named Christopher and kunte saw
um Ivy and walked us into epic and he
was about to leave there because he was
like the senior or whatever a r and I
decided uh you know what I'm gonna turn
it down and I'm gonna develop this girl
so we took two and a half years we also
got a deal from QC at the time
Interscope and a few other places and we
turned down all the deals because I knew
she wasn't ready also like I'm sure the
leverage wasn't great like you had a
million dollar advance yeah but you know
the terms probably weren't the greatest
no 100 for a new artists like that yeah
so what we did was we waited two years
uh two three years and she was living in
my house honestly I had this really big
closet and she slept in there and made
it a bedroom
um I had roommates at the time I was
roommates with Jake uh and in this house
in Sherman Oaks and yeah so she just you
know she dugged it out and I said look
if you listen to me you know you'll be
in a much better position in the next
few years and that's what happened and
then we ended up doing a JV partnership
with our label in uh Warner and you know
betting for her where she keeps you you
know keeps her tour rights and things
like that and it was very it was very
important for us to do that especially
you know you know seeing Russ and his
deals yeah like I saw him sign his first
deal with Columbia I was there and I
filmed it so it's like I saw the
contract and I knew that I'm like yo
this guy won he beat the system and I
was like this is I could do this too and
I think that's what Russ is so inspiring
because it's like he's literally showing
you guys how to get it you got me but
yeah most artists will go for that that
million dollars and then be stuck in a
deal and then once they blow through it
they'll be on Instagram complaining yeah
it's sad because you know once after
taxes and after you pay your lawyers and
after you pay you know your manager if
you have one at the time like which you
probably will do you have a manager yeah
I have a management yeah so I managed to
buy a company called uncomment which is
a division of macro and they did movies
like Judas and black Messiah and like
fences and cool stuff too or you can
just try to get into producing movies oh
that's already happening so yeah we got
four projects in development right now
including a TV series about my life so
I'm excited about that yeah so you're
doing like the TV thing all that yeah
that'd be big man yeah I'm just trying
to bring that same energy I bring the
music videos into the film world but
it's also like you know I was like I
want people to know that I was a hood
director right like I was a guy who just
pulled up to the Hood shooting identity
theft scammers and in Miami just pulling
up drug dealers whatever are all these
videos still on YouTube 100 you know um
yeah everyone in North Miami at the time
you know from The The J bucks to the DZ
the rappers the flow kids the young fees
to the icebergs you know all the Lex
promotions gang who introduced me to so
many local artists like I started
shooting videos for all of them and I
always thank them because like those
guys literally like they didn't care if
I didn't have documentation they didn't
care nothing they paid me cash under the
table and yeah and it really kept me
afloat yeah it really kept me afloat
yeah and then it was just it's kind of
crazy just to think about it honestly